si vous voulez bien regagner vos places
la séance est ouverte l'ordre du jour
appelle les questions au Gouvernement la
parole est au président Christian
Jacob merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Premier ministre
monsieur le Premier ministre quand
comprendrez-vous que votre arrogance et
votre
suffisanceor au plus haut point les
[Applaudissements]
Français devrait pourtant vous inciter à
davantage
d'humilité mais votre orgueil démesuré
vous a conduit une fois de plus à la
politique des coups de menton ces coups
de menton qui ne trompent plus personne
d'ailleurs mais finalement c'est cela
votre marque de fabrique pour la seconde
fois vous apprêtez à utiliser l'article
493 de notre
Constitution l'arme des faibles et des
pouvoirs affaiblis en février vous aviez
muselé votre majorité juste avant le
vote ça n'était certes pas glorieux mais
au moins le débat s'était déroulé
aujourd'hui en refusant que ce débat a
lieu dans l'hémicycle c'est le Parlement
que vous piétinez Monsieur le Premier
Ministre avec ce 493 ça n'est pas votre
majorité que vous bayonnez c'est
l'ensemble de l'Assemblée passe encore
que votre Ministre de
l'économie qui n'a jamais été élu qui n
d'ailleurs à lre qui est un pur produit
de la technocratie et eu cette idée mais
vous Monsieur le Premier Ministre vous
vous avez siégé sur ces bancs monsieur
le Premier ministre c'est une faute
lourde une faute à l'égard de votre
majorité que vous
humiliez une faute à l'égard de la
démocratie que vous
méprisez une faute à l'égard des
Français qui n'oublieront pas votre
brutalité cette faute là monsieur
Monsieur le Premier Ministre mérite une
sanction lourde
mérite un carton rouge et si vous aviez
le courage de retourner devant les urnes
monsieur le Premier ministre mais vous
n'aurez pas ce courage les Français vous
balerent comme on balait un féu de
paille
merci la
parole la parole est à Monsieur le
Premier Ministre manuel
Vals monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le président ob
j'admire toujours la finesse la qualité
de vos propos et surtout l'aspect nuancé
s'il vous plaît et d'ailleurs avant s
vous plaît avant de vous répondre sur le
fond et sur la méthode je vis vous dire
que dans tous les gouvernements de la 5e
République il y a eu des hommes et les
femmes qui ont été appelés par les
différents présidents de la République
sans avoir de mandats électifs qui ont
fait honneur à leur pays et pour un
gouliste que vous êtes vous devriez au
moins vous rappeler du chemin de Georges
pompilou et moi je veux remercier
Emmanuel Macron pour le travail qui a
été le sien pour le respect du Parlement
en siégeant en permanence et plutôt que
de vous attaquer aux personnes monsieur
Jacob ayez vous aussi et le courage de
présenter un projet alternatif et de
dire comme le pensent beaucoup de vos
parlementaires qu'ils auraient pu voter
ce texte parce qu'il est bon pour
l'économie parce qu'il est bon pour les
entreprises parce qu'il est bon pour les
salariés et parce qu'il est bon pour les
salariés vous êtes enfermé dans une
opposition stérile et mon devoir et le
devoir du gouvernement c'est d'aller
vite le pays a besoin de réformes le
pays a besoin d'avancer le pays a besoin
que nous soutenions la croissance la
compétitivité les petites et les
moyennes entreprises parce que ce sont
elles qui créent de la croissance de la
richesse et donc donc de l'emploi le 493
nous l'avons utilisé en première lecture
il y a eu un débat sans précédent une
coproduction législative entre le
Parlement et notamment la commission
spéciale et le gouvernement ce travail a
été encore prolongé la semaine dernière
au niveau de la commission spéciale et
je veux remercier François Brotte le
rapporteur Richard Ferrand et l'ensemble
des rapporteurs et des parlementaires de
droite ou de gauche qui ont travaillé au
sein de cette commission qui ont fait
Hur au Parlement je ne veux pas monsieur
Jacob pour mon pays que dans les 10
jours qui viennent il y ait une guerre
de tranchée dans cette assemblée pour
des raisons de posture politique et
devant les Français je me dois et nous
nous devons d'avancer de réformer c'est
le sens de ce texte que cela vous plaise
ou pas nous avançons parce que le pays a
besoin de
réformes merci monsieur le prememier
ministre